انا عشت في مصر فتره ودرست فيها
وهذه المساله كذلك تناولها كثير من
الباحثين ان الشخص يتخرج من الجامعه فيعمل
اخا المسلم في شركه الجماعه ويصلي في مسجد
الجماعه ويتزوج ابنه رئيس الشعبه واذا
تحرك حتى التاكسي يكون هو تاكسي الجماعه
فكان هنالك مجتمع مصري اخر صغير في حركه
الاخوان وهذه الطائفيه التي بدات منذ
مرحله مبكره اظن ان منذ ايام البنا منذ ان
كان لهم مدارس خاصه
ومعاهد خاصه للنساء وكانت له مستشفيات
خاصه وشركات خاصه وجيش خاص طبعا حار في
فلسطين فمنذ ذلك الوقت
نعم نعم هي حركه كبيره ولكنها كذلك تقيم
فاصل بينها وبين المجتمع المصري وهذا ادى
الى المواجهه التي حدثت مؤخرا وهذا ما شرط
اليه انا في احد المقالات التي كتبتها قبل
اربع ايام من التحول الذي قاده الرئيس
السيسي